everyone just not going to waste a lot
of time in theory but want to explain
what you should expect from this course
now basically we will be covering how do
you do phishing attacks or how do you
manage phishing campaigns for a
corporate penetration test in real life
okay and how do you do that with one of
the most advanced phishing frameworks in
the world which is known as Go Fish
now you need to understand one thing by
doovy to penetration testing assessments
that contains a social engineering when
you go and see one of the NIST special
publications that is 800 - one one five
one of my favorite publications this has
been outdated a little bit but you can
see it has almost 80 pages and it gives
you a lot of glance on how you should
perform a penetration test earlier life
in addition tests so here you will see
they have social engineering it should
be in this 15.3 social engineering so
when you go ahead and open these social
engineering aspects which is right here
you will understand that social
engineering simply attempts to trick
someone to reveal the information that's
what it is okay that's what it is
generally we are trying to get some of
the information which comes in the act
of reconnaissance phase through social
engineering otherwise we are trying to
gain access which comes in beginning
access phase right sometimes can get
extended to the maintaining access space
where we are trying to expand our reach
through social engineering we are
already in the system and we want to
attack other systems so we may apply
social engineering the most common ways
social engineering is utilized you can
see where here is one form of digital
social engineering is known as efficient
so that's what we generally do phishing
is your first line of attack right you
always start social engineering by the
way of fishing because even a focus on a
mass audience right and that's why you
need a dashboard you need a software
application to manage your phishing
attack your fishing camping now social
engineering may also be
used to target high-value individuals
generally you know different names given
as veiling spearfishing extrados castas
but the basic idea is when you are doing
a corporate level fishing you cannot
just use those little tools like social
engineering toolkit exact right sector
you can only use those tools and perform
a corporate level social engineering
attack right you cannot use those in
professional penetration testing you
need something bigger and that is why I
am going to show you how go fish can
help you with that
listen open-source fishing framework and
it's one of the best frameworks I have
ever used in all of my penetration tests
that are related to physical security or
social engineering assessments and the
main thing is we are not going to do it
on a local host which most of the other
people are teaching that's very
impractical we set up a live server that
runs a website that has this framework
this dashboard as well as that has SSL
so you never get caught with the HTTP
connections you will be spoofing your
email to send the phishing campaigns and
it's very very practical what you see in
the real life right so I hope you're
very interested with this let's go ahead
and cover the scores on Go Fish and
let's get started
we will grab the go fish framework which
will allow us to do phishing attacks
really simply and it will give us a lot
of power as compared to other possible
ways so coffee is a really great
framework written in the go language so
you can just go to like you can directly
go to get go fish comm or you can either
search for that so the search for go
fish here you will get the get go fish
dot-com which is for the download and
here's the github repository if you want
to check that out but let's just go
ahead and grab the garbage framework now
here you can just click on download
and depending upon the system which you
are using you can download the right one
here we have the 64-bit or a dog okay
there is the Linux 64-bit in my case you
may download depending upon what you are
using here so let me download it
let's save this I'll
now on to the stonewalling let's go back
and you can just see here I launched it
camping in three steps so you can see
how clear interface this is right here
in this image how clear and a good Anna
like structure it'll give you so it's a
really good panel I have used it a lot
and let's just go ahead and see if
download has completed so it's about ten
seconds
is this thing
Oh
so it has been downloaded yeah just in
yeah and let's open this up
and you will find the raw fish so let's
drag this thing on the desktop depending
upon where you want you can just have it
anywhere it has been extracted to
complete and now we don't need the
browser anymore here I would like to
rename it to go fish I don't like long
names
oh here it is
now here I've got the coffee framework
and let's see what are the files in this
so here is the readme file if you want
here is the configuration file in the
interrogation file if you just open it
up you can setup the ports so let me
show you guys that thing here are the
go-fish listening port here it will
listen and here are the go fish channel
server panel main server port so if you
want you can change this board 80 and 3
3 3 3 if you want it just all about on
you that this our go fish is and to run
go fish you just need to run this file
here with the terminal and that's all so
I'll see in the next lecture we will we
will just go ahead and explore go fish
we will learn this server and we'll see
what you can do with the coefficient how
it looks so thank you so much for
watching
welcome back everyone in this lecture we
will go ahead and start the Go Fish
server so in last lecture we just
downloaded this all folder and it sounds
simple to launch corphish you just open
it in a terminal and it's just the
running the go fish script here so it's
the full stop and then a power slash go
fish and this press enter it will start
the coffee server you can see starting
go fits over add this and go fish the
admin server add port this let's go
ahead and check that out
I'll open Firefox here
and let's go ahead and check that
127.0.0.1 port number three three three
three let's press ENTER now if you get
this kind of error nothing here and here
the error is like the GDP Heelys
handshake error so the first record does
not match looks like a TLS handshake now
what do you want to do is that make sure
you are not running is it on HTTP you
need to run it on HTTPS so HTTPS sorry
then colon forward slash forward slash
and this press enter and here it should
Lord if it gives you a security warning
no matters it's your local port just add
a security exception right out there
here is the place Island so it's really
simple the username is admin and the
password is go fish
so geo pH I s H this press enter and
here you are in the go fish
admin dashboard so I will start covering
up his go fish admin dashboard in the
next lecture but before that let's go
ahead
where is it and change the password so
you just need to click on the username
and here you can change the admin
username and all and the passwords and
here is the API key you can just go
ahead and reset it if you want so here
we have the
oh fish was the oil password and the new
password right here so
let's click on save
and you can see it updated successfully
and let's just go ahead and log out so
that is how you log in and log out and
text textures let's start exploring the
Gaul fish film work dashboard now I'll
just cancel and terminate this process
by ctrl C here so that is how you just
kill the server and that's all for this
lecture I'll see in the next one think
you're watching welcome back everyone in
this lecture I will like you all to move
your coffee framework on a VPS so that
you can connect a domain name with it
now you can do this thing on your Kali
Linux machine or basically any operating
system or anything whichever you are
using you can do this on that thing but
it will not be really convenient until
you have a static IP address because
your domain name the domain name which
you will be using actually you will need
to have a domain name as well but we can
take that for free from a lot of
services like freedom so that domain
name will not point to your your machine
and you will need a dynamic DNS and
there are a lot of troubles with that so
I would recommend to setup a VPS for
this kind of work now I am here in my
digital ocean dashboard and if you don't
know about the solution you can just
google it and get yourself a account
this lotion provides you $10 for free by
using the coupon code to10 currently it
is the coupon code maybe they will
change it so you might want to check
that and you can even use if you have
already an account you can use your
account if you don't have you can even
use my referral link that will
additionally give you $10 so that you
can process and you can proceed with
this lecture now I will create a droplet
here droplet is a VPS
I don't know what happened wrong so I'll
just go ahead and click create a droplet
here and it is still loading dissolution
is not working fine okay so here you
need to choose a opening system now you
can basically choose any operating
system I'll go with the Ubuntu oh it
doesn't really matters here you can
choose your size now this is just a
fishing server doesn't need a lot of RAM
so maybe $5 will be perfect oh I'll take
the Bangalore which is most near to me
and yeah that's all you can add SSH key
if you want but I won't add any here
let's create
and it'll just it created soon so till
then let me open my email
get the password because we are not
using a ssh key here
you
I'm going to take more than dominant our
whole setup to come
again the password has come maybe this
will also work in some seconds
what the mail on my phone it's not
working here as well
my intern connection is working right
is working and why not these both of
these services are working a catalyst
delusion
yeah so did Lauren given me the IP and
is now here but my mail service is
working again and the password will be
very long so I at
and open
a new tab
maybe that will work
so here is the password
I want to copy this password basically
and actually the IP Ezreal I'll just
copy everything I really don't need this
digitalocean panel anywhere we just
created the door plate that's all and
there is no role of this panel let me
minimize everything
it was this whole email
it means our
a text file here
you
we did I created that fire
waited on desktop
raided on desktop
here we have got it ex well it's edited
East the information
IP address username and a password so
let's go ahead and login in this server
I'll be using the terminal for this let
me open a new tab ok is this my go-fish
server running here I don't hit it
one thing if this is running or not
yeah so the recording is being done okay
so let's clear this screen now let's
move today
let's stop our root directory and let's
go ahead and login so we will just use
SSH and then we have root at the rate
this IP address
name is road
did the IP address controls you have two
V for paste who asked me for the
password it'll possibly ask me do you
want to connect with this
so yes okay sorry y-yes yes here it is
asking me for the password now I will
grab the password
ester that and press Enter
yeah so it is asking me to change the
password so first of all I am adding the
current password
okay I don't know what I type here let
me go back
so just in your password here
okay password change play the screen now
we need the coffee framework so I really
don't need it and let's open the Firefox
and get the go fish framework URL so we
have the get go fish
and
Eve
I am using a
it is uninstall to summon for is not
well I believe I'm using it for a bit
this is go ahead with dad only
it
odd
you
here is the 64-bit the next distribution
I'll copy this link and quickly the skin
I'll use the W gate to get this URL so W
get in the space this URL and press
Enter
and now it will download this go fish
framework for you guys now it may take
some time depending upon the server
speed and because the server is in India
this is going to take a lot of time
it is taking a lot of time here
I should have chosen anything else I
don't know why I chose Bangalore
so the speed is actually increasing and
increasing so it'll get downloaded where
its own basically yeah so it is keep on
increasing now
Hey all right is just one in yeah so we
just caught that thing downloaded the
screen and unzip the file so unzip and
just
press G and press tab to autocomplete
let's unzip this file again zip is not
currently stalled lesses install unzip
first of all unzipped
it would be installed in this
yeah it is now installed let's try this
so we just install unzip and now we are
extracting everything out from that
directory and here we just extracted
everything so if I just list then we
have a folder and we have the file so we
are basically concerned with default or
only now I will go ahead and leave the
go fish framework server running so what
I can do is I will first of all move to
the go fish directory here
okay
and
here as we that configuration file
contains D listening port in the callee
machine now we would like to edit it
because in Kali machine we were on the
machine and we were able to use the
local port but in this case we are using
it on EVPs and we will not be able to
accesses before like if we don't edit it
so you can use any text editor I will go
with the Nano
now here you will see that the port is
1/7 2.0 0.1 and we need to edit it to
0.0 0.0
here we are 0.0.0.0 and that's all and I
would actually change the port
it'll be one seven to four
sorry
I just changed the port for
convenience basically and that is
everything done so I will just press
control X
and the why in press enter
and clear the screen and that's all now
you just need to start your go fish
server sorry
Go Fish server or basically I believe
that on a VPS we need to add the
executable permission so I will add th
mod + X
permission executable permission to go
fish here
said that and now I believe we can just
start sorry we can just start this over
so here we have dot slash Go Fish press
enter and here it has started
successfully so we really don't need it
now
and now you can access your server okay
I forgot what was the IP address this is
the IP address
now this is not the IP address we need
the IP address of the server basically
and later on we will even not need the
IP address because we will add a domain
name to this server so at the moment we
need the IP address but in next lecture
we will add a domain name to this but
that it'll be able to point to that so
now we have this IP address again you
can just see eh not found the okay sorry
we are not using the port here
now here you can see the same error
which means that we are not using the
HTTPS version
okay it'll show me a security exception
but I know this is my side so it is
really secure an exception and I'll just
go with the confirm security
oh here is the Go Fish framework of a
login and change the password as soon as
possible so it is the goal which is the
default
Here I am in the dashboard and let's go
ahead and change the password soon so
here we have
it is gobhi usage and the new password
I just changed the password here
yeah it got successfully changed
basically
and I even looked out let's go ahead and
check that again we have Edmund
you
yeah so now we are able to login so
password has changed successfully
yeah that is how we set up go fish on a
VPS and from now in next lecture we will
basically set up a we'll set up yes a
domain name to this server so that we
can proceed with a domain name and then
we have a lot of works to do after that
so we will just need a domain name
basically and then we can start fishing
and making the profiles landing pages
email templates user groups campaigns
and we can start fishing with the go
fish so that was all for this lecture I
see you the next one thank you for
watching
welcome back everyone in the last
lecture we set up the VPS with the Go
Fish framework and in this lecture we
want to have a domain name pointing to
that VPS so that we can use it now I
would take a domain name from free Nam
Kham that gives the domain names were
free for one year and if you want you
can basically get registered with a
domain name that is most near to your
target real domain name that will be a
good thing to do here but here let's go
ahead and sign in first
I really don't know how many domains I
will have in that account
I'm really not sure about it
taking a little slow because of the VPN
because maybe I am using
you
I don't know why it's not loading up
that is working fine and you see that
oh here again it just got loaded up as
soon as I press ENTER yeah so I will
sign up at Google here
they test account
this will not have any domain name
now I'll go to services the main names
which it is in names
but just our domain here it is
here we will get a domain name so let's
get it I mean named linear to us which
will be like let's say pH MC securities
our website is PSM securities dot org
but let's get the pH MC securities
thought maybe CFG L whatever is
available here you can see we have a lot
and I believe that the ml one looks a
little lizard so I'll click on get it
now
and I will just check out with this
domain name
we can check out
and I'll need to fill some details here
basically oh I'll get it
for one year maybe
okay
now we have used the endless for this
domain name so we will configure this
thing later let's go ahead and continue
and proceed with this
right and here we want to fill in all
the details
you
I'll add my details basically here so he
would start
was
you
obviously on that this one investment
will work anywhere but still I'll just
complete the order
okay there is a problem
I
at this [ __ ] here
hey let me finish it really fast now
right what's left now this
here I forgot to take this thing and
that is why I didn't complete it now in
this case it should get me a domain name
now I have got the domain name let's go
ahead to the client area we have the
services my domains here in my domains
we'll go ahead and click on manage
domain
and they will go ahead to the name
service basically so it should be here
management tools and name service now we
will use the name servers of the digital
ocean because we are using the digital
ocean here because right
these lotions nameserver RNs one dot
just washing calm
ns-two door - lotion calm and NST lure
digitalocean calm
and you can just leave the fourth one
deleted and fine as well so let's go
ahead and change the name servers it may
take up to 24 hours to propagate this
domain name basically so we are not sure
if this domain name is gonna work at
this time but still we will go ahead and
configure our digitalocean account
all right this is thing else
it's Logan
you
but we should have the droplet here here
it is and in right here we have a de
domain in more so maybe this interface
will change as the solution has sent me
the email today that there will be
changing the interface I'm actually not
sure here in the domain name you can
just add a domain name which ever you
have caught for me I have got the PMC
security stud ml
here we are and the server and this
click on a domain
Oh
yes yeah here we have got some default
name DNS records maintained here but
yeah we really don't need to care about
them we yeah we really don't need to get
about them is this go to droplet here
and let's just if our domain name is
working so our port is 1 7 2 4
and I'm quite sure that this domain name
will not work because of the
okay so the main name is actually
working I didn't expect it a little just
get propagated this soon so we want to
use HTTP sorry what I just typed here
STD B is
we'll add the security exception for
this domain i domain because
here is the domain name running the golf
a server and here I can vary the easily
man password is I actually changed that
I believe
so here is the domain name running
coffee server this is a VPS and now we
can do a lot of things now what I would
recommend is to go head in digitalocean
and all right here and open a support
ticket basically so where is the support
ticket I forgot yeah here is the support
an open a support ticket and say that
please unblock my SMTP server please
allow me to send emails and write in
that about this course that you are
practicing this course and give them a
link of this course and tell them that
your practice in this course and you
will not do anything illegally you are
going to test it on your own email ids
and this is a phishing server but you
hereby guarantee that you will not do
anything illegal here now you can tell
them and they should basically unlock
your SMTP server you should try to make
convince them so if you are not able to
convince them please let us know in the
questions and we will try from our end
now this was the thing which you need to
do and if you are not able to get
testing working with your domain name
you should go ahead and check within to
int or DNS comm slash your domain name
so here is my domain name into DNS comm
slash your domain name and just check
which DNS servers and which IP is it
using here you should find that DNS
servers are changed and they are on
these IPS basically and if these is if
this is working right here it should
mean that your domain has propagated
successfully if it is not it should mean
that like you should wait for at least
24 hours to 48 hours now this was all
about setting up go fish now we are
ready to start fishing and I'll see you
guys in the next lecture where we will
start learning this thing so see you
then thank you for watching
welcome back everyone in this lecture we
want to get a ssl certificate for our
fishing servers so that no user gets a
warning about HTTP is so let's go ahead
and get that thing and I would also like
to introduce screen to you guys so we
have a program called SCR EE in now you
can just go ahead and type in app - get
install screen if you guys need to
install that so just go ahead and run
this command if it is already installed
it will show you this install otherwise
it will give you an option to install it
and after that you want to type in ser
EE n make sure you are logged in to your
your VPS I am here let's assess in my
VPS you can just see know that did it
you want to so just type in screen and
just press ENTER and it will just show
you something just press ENTER again and
now you can just go ahead and run your
server so if I just here just yeah if I
just go ahead and run my server now hey
let me move to the Go Fish directory
first
here this now if I just go ahead and run
this server
so here it is running and now what I can
do is I can press control a so control a
and now D or D control a and D D is for
detach and now I can just go ahead and
close my session my SSH session I can
just close this window and still that
Goffin server will run in background
always if I want to stop that server I
can again go ahead and type in screen
now I don't want to press ENTER here I
would go ahead and press - are to
reattach the last session so here you
can see it will be running and now you
can just go ahead and stop it if you
want
that is how screen will help you to run
your server 24 by 7 and without need to
SSH in pad now here's the website 0
ssl.com which provides to you I believe
it they provide let's encrypt free SSL
certificate so we want to go ahead and
get the SSL certificate from them
now here you can just enter the email if
you want here you have the domain name
so like you can just enter the domain
name whichever you have got
I have got this domain name from them I
said their turns Indonesian make sure
you are on DNS verification here and
just go ahead and click on next this
okay and you do you want it actually be
sorry the WWE Arjun - so just click on
yes
and it'll generate an in CSR which will
be right here you can then download that
file for future reference maybe you will
need that in future anyhow but yeah like
let's say we will even download that
thing and after it generates the CSR
here you will again click on next it
will generate what this it will generate
a let's encrypt key for you guys and
then you can also download that thing so
we just want these files in this lecture
in the next lecture we will go ahead and
use those files we'll go ahead and get
those files in the server so I'm just
waiting for it now it may take up to
five minutes also so just wait and give
it some time
it has generated me the seas as are so I
will just download this thing
have it
now again click on next and this time it
will create the account key
you
it's taking a little long but accept
this get me the account key within one
to two minutes I'm just reading for it
and as soon as you download this will
click on next and then it will ask us to
verify the domain name so that like
it'll ask us that is if this domain
belongs to us only it will make sure
that and I am still waiting I don't know
why it's taking a lot of time ok it has
downloaded it
sorry degenerate did it and now
downloading it up that is how I just
downloaded that and let's just click on
next and this time it'll ask me for the
verification basically
I have clicked on next here
make sure you are on the DNS
verification
it is it is asking me for the domain
verification and it'll ask me to create
these records so for this I will go to
my distortion panel here here I will go
to networking and maybe this interface
will change in some time they are saying
this thing but here I will go to domains
okay here is the domain name then I will
just go to I believe I will go to more
and manage domain
and it should be similar in other
previous providers as well almost
similar and here I will just create the
txt record so txt record okay now it is
giving me the Dixie record should with
this one
with the value of this one so let's find
here should be the value and this is the
host name so host name will be the first
thing which it is giving you and then we
have the value here so just copy this up
and paste it in the value value and just
click on create record
okay created successfully let's create
second record as well so here we have
that
we have hostname and we have D value
hey one second yeah pop it that and here
paste it and create record now as soon
as you create these two records so we
want these two txt records here are they
we have now been created we can proceed
for the verification now the problem is
that this might take some time you can
just see here 15 to 20 minutes before
clicking next so I will actually you
know I'm not actually sure but
we've gone next year
you
okay it says it has failed
so it has not been graded still and I
actually need to wait for that basically
let us change the records so these
records got change here
so I need to modify the hem and I'll
just go ahead and edit these
this is the main issue so you know you
need to wait for around like whatever
they are saying the time so you need to
wait for that okay i pasted the wrong
value here and they rode a [ __ ] how am i
doing this one is to be added at this
www record
yeah
yeah and this is www well you
you
I obviously created these records but
they are not visible so I actually need
to wait for 15 to 20 minutes and I don't
want to waste a lot of time for you guys
so I'll see you guys in the next lecture
where I'll be up with these records so
these records will be up and running so
you know we'll just try this thing and
I'll see you guys in the next lecture so
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you then hey welcome back everyone in
the last video we just created our txt
records but actually I just noticed that
we did a little mistake out there so you
can just see here let's say we want to
create this record let's say this one so
first one you know if you just copy and
paste this thing here I have actually
solved this now you can see here this
dot Pete and the cigar disorder ml is
repeating two times which should not be
the case
so you basically need to remove this dot
p h MC dot M L and you just need this
part of the D record so a cm each
underscore a CMA - challenge so this
should be the record and then here
should be the value now the thing is
that with the www which is the second
record you will not be able to create it
because you have not created the www
record so you basically need to create
twww record first and that should be a
Syrian record so go to cname just say
add www here and just add at the red
sign here just click on create record
and that's all that is how you create
the www record and as soon as you create
that you can now go ahead and create D
the taken record here so just add this
thing underscore is eme - challenge or
www and add the value here so the value
given to us is this
the value here is click on add record
now there is a way to check your records
through the you know like what it is to
the terminal you can also go ahead ahead
and do ms to MX toolbox txt record test
the MX toolbox is the one which I would
recommend so here DNS lookup text or a
call here and you just want to copy and
paste these records in the test it will
just show you if they exist or not here
you just want to paste this thing and
test for the record and a case um okay
this yeah here you can see DNS record
has been published let's check the
second one which we just published so it
will like it should be there here we
have text lookup
okay so it again says that it has been
published and that was just a quick fix
of our last mistake so let's go ahead
and yeah go to zero and so let's click
on next
okay I just clicked on that and it is
not checking and it should basically get
the records because they have already
been created and we have verified that
thing too
okay there is some unexpected error here
you know this error was something else I
really don't know I will just go ahead
and try once again with the records
I'm okay I just clicked next and the
certificate is basically yeah it is
basically ready so what I have to renew
and repeat the process using the same a
leaky and CSR so if you have downloaded
those two files you can just go ahead
and open them and paste them and just
click on next to renew your certificate
and now we have this under difficut has
been downloaded right in made so here we
have that thing
we will now download the certificate
okay
I will click on this
I believe I have already downloaded this
one
okay don't mean yeah I have not
downloaded that
difficut has been done now we have the
domain key
okay we also got the domain key here on
domain certificate here now we can go
ahead and set up the certificate in that
what it is in the server so let's go
ahead and do that I really don't need it
something else I was I mean there's
something else I was working
earlier let's go ahead to the terminal
this is also something else yeah here is
the terminal let's close this server and
let's go to config dot yes and basically
I'll go to nano
config dot Jason
now here you will see actually this is a
true but I change it to false let me
just again do it on true because I
remember it was true I was just doing
some testing basically now here we have
this example of CRT and Kiro CRT so we
will just go ahead and change it to we
will just change this domain basically
example to the domain name let's go
ahead and change that
okay now we will change it to be its MC
mmm
right we also have this key to change
you
right so this works you can basically
give it any name but I just give it this
name to remember this thing so I'll just
press control X Y and I'll just press
ENTER before that you can just see these
headings it should be almost the same so
now I just press control C now we need
to create this certificate file and the
key file so for that I will do is I will
just copied this file this file I'll
just copy this hit the name and I'll
just edit this file and so I will just
type in CP Corphish - Edmond not CRT so
I will copy this thing to the same
directory with the name of it was pH MCS
Hiyori T's okay sorry
ehm c and c CU rit IES dot ml dot c RT
I just press that thing would check so
here we have this under difficut and i
will also do the same for the key here
at this time I'll
kids little lagging this connection is
little lagging here
and something is wrong with my internet
at this time
yeah so now okay it is now working at
it's this again yeah so I'll just
manually edit this here I will enter key
and here
Yuriy di es not ki thank you sorry dot
mm as well
I'm a latke I believe everything is fine
I just clone that thing now we will edit
these
well we happy times insecurities with em
a lot certificate first
here we have a the certificate we will
just make it blank basically
if now
is going to take a little time and
little lag because the VP s and my
connection is not working correctly here
we will just remove everything from it
and we will paste
d files which we have got from zero SSL
so we have bought a it should be here
you forgot it domain certificate
oh just control a control C closet
and here control-shift we
who basically based everything
yeah so it is right here and control X Y
and enter and let's again check the file
so I just type the same thing yeah it is
now fine so let's do this thing for ki
as well
here it is ducky
oh that's delete everything
you know you can even use the touch
command to create these files I just did
it to make sure that I am like you know
I have the correct format and also that
was just a precaution you can just go
ahead and use the touch command to
create these files in control a control
see
and here control-shift vie
at the key yeah so control-x
why
I believe I press right
in ya
oh actually I need to I want to wait I
believe there is something wrong
yeah yeah at this press enter here clear
the screen
and confirm that it is a looking fine it
will just go there yeah so it is
actually fine
yep now basically we have got everything
here let's just make sure the name is
correct pH MCC care at least what I'm a
latke so let's go ahead and edit the
like check the configuration file once
again
if we have p.m. physically stored em a
lot CRT and owe them a lot e SEC URI TI
es su RIT is yes so this looks pretty
fine here right
I believe I have some problem here it
should be port 80 here it is not already
also it should actually when you are
using the you know when you are using
this thing EVPs it should be basically
four four three here
and I will even go ahead and add this
thing to Crewe
they'll see the configurations these are
the exact contributions now I will close
this thing give
and
and I will start this server here let me
do it manually
of door - Hegeman autocomplete
I mean I will I have to do
so I just started this server
now it has actually started this server
so what I can do is I you know I am
using this screen which we discussed in
a later video so I'll just press control
a and D
so now I had you'd ask that screen here
now let's go ahead and try to visit the
website each I'm city Gary's dot ml
and it says unable to connect
wait a minute because we are not using
in as HTTP maybe
what I edit here
yeah so HTTP is working fine you can see
there is a green lock and this is from
let's encrypt so that is how we get the
SSN certificate and let's go ahead 1 7 2
4 let's go ahead and basically get the
he's ever working
you know you can also add the SSL
certificate of login page you know this
is just an exception which we added here
right we can even go ahead and add this
to a certificate which we created so the
same certificate can be shared by both
of these port and I will basically
change this thing
so
Green - are
okay here is this control-c to break the
server here and I will add it the Nano
configuration though Jason and I will
change this thing to the real
certificate which we have just got so pH
MCS ECU RIT ie s dot ml and this one as
well
eh MC secu rit IES dot ml e right so
everything is fine here I'll just go
ahead and press ctrl X and then Y and
I'll just press ENTER and again start
the server
control a and D and I will now forget
this thing I really never need to login
in this again
now make sure you don't forget to renew
your essays a certificate after I
believe it it should be after three
months here you will find some
some information on the renew so I would
recommend you renew it on every yeah it
is 90 days so you need to renew it after
90 days and it will be the same
procedure so that's
all done that's all for this lecture and
let me assure you guys the log in page
this time
we'll take the certificate from let's
encrypt so okay it's still showing me a
security exception but let me
had this remove the security exception
yeah you can just see it is now actually
let's encrypt certificate you can see
that right so that was all in this
lecture and from next lecture we will
actually start working and start our
fishing but thank you so much for
watching
hey welcome ak1 in this lecture we will
actually go ahead and explore the
coffee's dashboard so I have actually
done some kind of you know I've done
some kind of basic testing here so just
don't remember the password now
yeah this is the password so I am able
to basically login so I really don't you
know that let me to show you that here I
have got some things here let me clear
the dashboard that you can basically see
how it's going to be done in the real
life so I'm just going to clear
everything you get a fresh installation
almost fresh installation here I will
delete everything
just testing this stuff up so this is
about that
you always want to start from left to
right which is from sending profile to
the dashboard basically so
you know and in Camping's I believe
there should be nothing
there is one
okay the dashboard should be now clean
basically yeah so let's go ahead and
start with the sending profile now
sending profile is really simple you
will need to enter the SMTP web server
here basically so what I'm going to do
is
[Music]
Oh
he'll add my gmail ending profile here
so I'll add my gmail basically you want
to get a SMTP which allow you to spoof
your email like SMTP to go is a really
good example and we will basically cover
SMTP to go in the last lecture but for
that like before that we will setup it
with the Gmail okay so first of all you
want to test for Gmail SMTP settings
and you should obviously have a gmail
account for this or you can basically
choose any any email provider and search
for their email settings
now we have here is an SMTP dot okay
where this yeah so SMTP server is this
one
then we have the world is five eight
seven
so in SMTP host we want to add the
server then colon and port so it was it
eight seven five it is five eight seven
right
I will just add that five eight seven
now username will be your email ID
well let's use another one
our password will be your gmail account
password
then you have a profile name so it will
be
except as email and then you have like
name can be anything then you have the
from-- so I would like to send it from
the name of text server and then
brackets and then my email ID
now basically this is the field where
you have everything with spoofing if I
wanted to send this email from Bill
Gates I will add Bill Gates here and in
the brackets I will have bill at delayed
microsoft.com so this is where the
sender the receiver will see who the
message whom the person has sent this
message this is the main thing but with
Gmail I'm quite sure they will not allow
you to send this from another email
before that we will basically use some
others SMTP relays in the last chapters
but till then we will like we want to
target everything else with the
Camping's user groups email templates
and landing page so till then just go
ahead and get this thing and here you
have the test email basically so you can
send this test email to anyone
okay
the send a test email
you
okay now it says that please log in via
a browser now gmail is not allowing me
to send the email so this might be
because less secure apps are not
available on that
email account
now you can basically go ahead and
change your settings okay that email
account is even not listed here you know
guys at this time I'm a little blank
because that email account I'll have to
add that him in here
now you want to search for how to enable
less secure apps for signing you can
just see it basically blog designing so
if you want to enable the less secure
apps my account
now this will be different for all
providers
and actually I'm not sure where this
will be your sign-in and security maybe
right let's go in that
here we should have something light like
let's secure a less secure apps
I am not able to
find that yeah here it is allow less
secure apps I will just own it and now I
will be able to send it SD me
it is still blocking me here
so I believe I will not be able to use
Gmail guys so let's see if
I can do something with this otherwise I
will make another account and I'll just
get back with that
you
if I just cancel this I'll try again
if so I'm not able to do that
I will not be able to do that because
gmail is not allowing me to use your
account now I will get a account fast
outlook will allow me
and I'm quite sure I already have made
an outlook for this kind of testing here
it should be an account I will just
check that with logging in so outlook
SMTP
headings hurry the the settings is wrong
there einen let's try
you
oh no my connection is gone here slow at
this
something's really wrong
right let's check I believe I have an
account
it's insecurities
you
I did
outlook.com
yeah I I remember I have this account
let me check the password if able to
login okay this is wrong
maybe this password
yeah I got the password so I can
basically use the SMTP here this is the
SMTP
we need the SMD B
we'll get the SMTP settings he'll then
let me add these your name and password
here
we have it as eh emcee securities
I have the password as
yes
and ever
at the empty air as well
well pH MC
Unity's here and E
and
SMTP server so the port is again five
eight seven and the server is this one
you have 587 this same 587 so I will
just say in the SMTP here
okay that's all with these settings
let's do a test again oh it should work
fine
I just hope it will send the email
you
akiza's or for it yeah emails and so now
the test was successful
let's week now we can just go ahead and
just save this profile I even got the
email on my phone actually we just saved
this profile and okay I will rename it
to acknowledge email account so I will
rename it here
you just make sure I am
incorrectly pH MC Outlook account right
let's disable
you know in later video we will try to
get an SMTP server which will allow us
to send spoofed email but now this will
not allow us so in next lecture we will
cover up the landing page and the email
template till then take the leaves or
thank you so much for watching
hey welcome back guys in last lecture we
configured the SMTP profile in this
lecture we will talk about the landing
page and the email template so let's go
to a landing page and it's really a
great feature in Go Fish framework that
you can just give it a name let me just
give it a spoke
okay now I am NOT saying anything wrong
about Facebook here I am just using it
for the testing purposes and I can
basically use any website but you know
this is the most common one which people
try to fish I'll just click on import
site and I will add the URL of the page
here of facebook.com I'll just click on
import
and here it has done all the work for me
I just want to click on captured
submitted data and capture passwords and
then redirect the users to hold on
yeah okay then redirect the users to
real Hesburgh comm after they submit
their data to me I'll just click on save
page
and hold on for a moment
yeah the Facebook page has been saved
and I'll just go ahead and click create
an email template now so landing page
was the page where a visitor will go and
submit his data email template is the
the email which he will receive or we
have
okay Facebook email I will even import
the email here how to import the email
you basically you know like you can add
your own email in the HTML format but a
really important old email from my
account
I believe this account was used for
Facebook
not before
yeah I have a message with from Facebook
this is an old email from Facebook to me
right
or will it work is there any other email
which I have
oh yeah
against
and so I only have one email from
Facebook basically on this account and I
will actually work with that only but
this will be Heyward it is working
you
you know it's not even showing me the
females leave Internet is working fine
now
you
you want to search
you
I don't even have a Facebook account and
this aha email for the testing purposes
guys you know
I believe there should be something in
social oh sure there is
what shall I
member
yes for the testing purposes okay but
Louis I will I will actually take this
Cora email okay wasn't all answer
requests to me this is just for the
testing purpose you can basically like
you can basically change the like you
can have the Facebook email as also now
you want to view the source of the email
so I will just click on show it is not
here
oh sure it is no will take me to the
source of email this is source and there
should be a copy to clipboard button
here it is I just copied that thing to
court and I will here paste this thing
and make sure this is ticked and let's
go ahead and click on import
Oh like this will import everything now
I didn't have that Facebook message you
can even have a Facebook message hey I
will actually change it to Cora
what does question
pretty cool here am i typing
so this is just for the testing purposes
you can add anything let's just save it
he also made an email template let's
create users in group
users in the group are just a group to
whom you want to send this email so
testing
rope and in this you want to you can
even import the CSV file or you can add
the group manually so sagar
unserved other or let me get it on my
gmail the CEO added now i have gotten
only one person in my group i will click
on save change and let's go to camping
lets me get camping now
you
in campaigns we want to click on new
campaigns I'm just waiting for this
inter stop
let's create a camping camping name will
be
test email template which email you want
to use I will use the quota question
request a which landing page I will use
the Facebook now they don't have any
connection but I am just using it for
the testing purposes now here comes the
URL benefit I will add the HTTP version
okay let's check the syntax it is
correct so pay attention here it is not
ml with HTTPS here the deal time let's
just leave it as it is sending profile
will be pH and see out look and group
will be this one let's end this camping
camping [ __ ] dude
say it's ending
I would basically go to dashboard here
it says killed I don't
all right cute it
now there are no errors but it actually
cured
it does still the setters are still
sending and I'll get back to you guys in
the next video where you know like when
I'll receive this email so I'll open the
email and I'll show you guys so on the
dashboard you can basically see the
emails sent a email has been sent here
is the email opened email click link and
this I metadata so let's do this thing
in the next video here I had the timely
lamentations so I'll see you guys in the
next lecture thank you so much for
watching
hey welcome back guys in this lecture
let's go ahead and open a private tab
and let's visit the email so basically
let's visit our gmail account and see
what happens when we go ahead and surf
the the things are right here
every our sign
you
let's enter the email here
I believe this is the password
I am able to lock them and now you will
just see
yet here is the email which we sent
let's open it
this is email is coming from Outlook
calm but you can even spoof it with a
custom SMTP now here it seems like a
really littered email but as soon as we
click on a right answer here it will
take us to our page you can just see
that it is taking us to our fake page
this is the fake Facebook page here you
can just see that here I don't know why
it's not loading these images perfectly
but that can be like you know that can
be some issue with the cloning this side
so you can just go ahead and to
facebook.com right click view page
source and you can add the source
manually but no problems let's add some
test things here starter oneself
Adelaide Thunderdome okay in password
this is
test
let's press ENTER and you can see that
it will redirect me to facebook.com the
real Facebook
right now there were some problems in
the landing page here you can see there
is some problem basically
as try to visit the website also
we need the HTTPS
okay I directly I cannot directly visit
this site I want to check this site
again
you can see even Gmail is not giving me
any issues about the fake phishing
website and all now guys there is some
problem with the de cloning of site here
you can just say this is not working at
all this is some problem with cloning so
you might just go ahead and enter the
correct source of the page this is some
problem in cloning when we create some
landing page but let's go ahead and
check the dashboard let's refresh the
dashboard here you see emails and email
open click link and submitted data now
it is saying submitted data like it is
not showing me any submitted data but
you know we actually submitted that data
so there is a little problem with the
framework here
let's go ahead and try something else
let's go ahead and create another
landing page
and at this time maybe the you know like
my website
so
let's go ahead and do that
import now I'm not white yeah sorry
I'm not quite sure we'll like it we'll
be able to import my site correctly or
not
it was able to do at a great
let's not redirect the user anywhere
so we have got the bail let's
you know let's go ahead and read one
more camping here
and let's do this thing on a test email
this time
if
let's add this test email user basically
this is the demo email
you
I added the second user as well
I'm sorry I am making a new group right
our problems I just made a new group
here and Milt
let's launch one more camping
camping
a guerrilla website template will be
let's add the same template eyesight
you
so everything is fine sending profile
will be the same and the group will be
temp Minister let's launch this camping
as well so it will send me the email
within 1 minute now
it says sending but it should basically
in the Camping's
you know you can basically monitor all
of them but I really don't need this
camping and deleted
it is saying good but it should
basically add that thing within one
minute
in progress
you
email sent let's see that yeah here we
have also received
Oh
at MIDI here is the email that visited
yeah so now this is a perfect clone of
my website right go ahead and try this
thing Edmund Edmund
let's login no I'm not sure if this fell
only yes so it is again redirecting me
there only because we didn't specified
anything I'm not sure why it was not
capturing the data
but
maybe it only captures yeah
here you see submitted data as well you
can basically go ahead and see the
results here
okay
and in the results you have submitted
data right
you you have that submitted data
you can basically I believe you can even
or these thing are not sure which one to
export but I will export both of them
but this is the raw data
we'll open link and permitted the data
it
you
and the results
so it says
results can be exported like that
actually I want to check something else
oh you know like I'll get back to you
guys in the next lecture where we will
do something else I I really want to
show you guys something else I'll see
you guys in the next lecture thank you
so much for watching
he will come again now you know like I
was I was like finding this thing so I
don't know I just missed this arrow here
so here you can just see there is a
small arrow he can click on this and it
will show you the exact timeline for the
person with the exact date and time as
well and here you have the deeply
credentials and the view details you can
click here and it will even show you the
credentials whose team in purpose and
like I was just trying to get where this
is not getting this thing now you can
just see where do you want the
credentials to be submitted to so you
know the me like you can just click here
replay credentials it will just try to
log you with these credentials if it is
able to its go ahead and try that
it will just redirect to my site with
the given credentials and it will not be
able to allowed me in because the
credentials are you know they are fake
here you can see cookies are blocked and
not supported by the web browser you
must enable cookies who use WordPress
not actually the cookies are blocked so
I'm not able to do that and I believe my
site will not allow me to do this kind
of work but you can just click on replay
credentials and it will try to log you
in the real account with D credentials
permitted by the user so that's one way
you can actually go ahead and land in
the users account so this was all about
corphish only thing left is the SMTP
profile which enables you to send
message through any email you can see
the email came from PMC securely stored
at the it outlook.com let's go ahead and
change it to pH NCE securities no let's
go ahead and change it to dance email
which is you know the PM's email which
is the Dan at the rate pH MCE securities
dot org so let's change it to that and
basically in next lecture we will try to
do this kind of stuff and I'm really
curious about that to move the email
address
see you guys till then thank you so much
for watching so welcome back guys this
is the final lecture about the you know
about the fishing with go fish so in
this lecture I will talk about the email
spoofing now for email spoofing it's
really simple you need any SMTP server
that allow you to send email without the
verification of the domain name SMTP to
go is one of them there are a lot there
are plenty of them now I don't say that
you guys should do this and I am NOT
pointing anything to SMTP to go here you
know like this if you use this kind of
work on daily basis if you really want
to do this you can set up your own SMTP
server but I'm just going to use it in a
really controlled manner okay I will
just do it in a really controlled manner
to me only if you want to do it or with
others you might want to get
a paid smtp server or might want to set
your own smtp server on a VPS but I'll
do it on a controlled manner because you
know this also harmed the reputation of
the company so SMTP to go IP address
might get harm from this so I'll do it
in a really controlled manner okay
so let's go to sending profile now for
this you can just go to SMTP to go and
get yourself a account this will be this
is a free account which I am using here
so I'll just add a profile here so we
have SMTP
to go
five
from I will send this email from you
know from
core our team
the sender will be will be the
no reply
I did
Tom
a host is this one port it's two five
two five
user name is my
SMTP Togo username which is exactly the
same
you
as what is your SMTP to go password
and that's all now you don't want to
click on send test email because this
will left SMTP to go know that you are
sending a spoof email and they will ban
your account okay you just want to
directly send it now I believe I said
that we will be using dance email which
is done I did it pH I'm physically org
with DP HMC email but let's use the kora
email this seems you know this seems
more genuine and how to do I just save
that setting
I'm not her
if they will allow me to do this kind of
work okay if I just get banned you want
to try another less empty okay it's go
to a dashboard or let's just go to
camping here
you camping
everything will be basically the same
okay so add anything
mattress
you
right wing profile as in Thibodaux the
name is Stu testy let's launch this
camping and maybe they will just ban me
or doing this kind of work
but this you can basically you know you
can just go ahead and get yourself some
kind of SMTP that allow you to do its
kind of work or you can actually go
ahead and it's a sending but I believe
it will just fail
you
you know I really
as email sent one eye all this is the
old email I want
in progress okay great
okay it is giving me the error as
expected so the error should be that
they banned me right now see
okay incorrect authentication data
really I believe I have the correct
authentication sending profiles
you know if I just
to do five to five right
yeah we'll fight to five
if I just go to my dashboard I don't
want to see a band a message here
this is an old email basically which
says 300% bounce rate believe I believe
I added something wrong in the
in the port here NTP to go calm it's a
sick killer
okay this was the thing our ID IES
let's save it
let's we should do that camping
if we have that II have a lists papi
this campaign
everything will be already done the
selected group analysis look
you
okay camping [ __ ] the old I want to I
really want this
there's email sent really consent was it
this fast Wow let's go ahead and check
that email refreshing is temporary email
okay we got that right here Cora team no
reply at the red quorum you can se that
it delivered my email right maybe this
email can basically land in a hand
folder of a lot of providers you can the
see email has been spoofed successfully
and I fear they would have just pan me
for this thing
that
okay actually doesn't land in spam so
that is why they didn't ban me and if I
send this thing to Gmail maybe it'll
land in spam and they will ban me up oh
I can just see it is taking me to the
phishing page it is even HTTPS no
chances for anyone to survive this kind
of attack in the sea no chances for
anyone to survive this kind of like only
thing is if it land in spam it's all up
to you maybe you might want to do a fake
call with a spoof caller a message which
convinced the user to open that spam
email and like it opens which convinced
them to submit the data it's all up to
you how you make them realize that was
all about phishing and I'll see you guys
in the next lectures thank you so much
for watching